benvenuti se vi state chiedendo cosa ci
facciamo io e enrico seduti qui è la
domanda giusta perché neanche noi lo
sappiamo partiamo colpire su instagram
vi abbiamo chiesto di mandarci degli
obblighi o delle verità da eseguire e
pagherà ci stavamo la tua frase migliore
vediamo che cosa ci avete scritto
facciamo un preambolo però il nostro
primo video se fa cagare
non ci crederete mai comincio io posso
bailey rita posizione preferita per fare
sesso non rispondete dovete leccare la
scena dell'altro ma chi ti cinquia
ramente io sfondo
ancestrale paola ti amo tanto
come un forsennato
persistentemente
sei stato molto chiaro a me piace
avere lei lei
all
la lana diamo al suolo questa merda di
casa ci teniamo comunque a precisare che
gianmarco siamo congiunti e negativi
obbligo e ricorsi la faccia di paola ora
velasco post scriptum chiamo tanto
tesoruccio mio far sistemare la cena
degli occhiali meno male il problema è
che io la cena delle chiare cielo a casa
e siamo nello spazio mi sembra perfetta
ecco qua perfetta questa mattina a sera
ci vedi bene che ci son pubblico per
comprare dei nuovi occhiali e scegliere
i buoni non avrebbe senso comprarne di
nuovi fate un video di allenamento con
gabriele al posto di guglielmo pronto
cassa c'è la festa tra un'ora sulla luna
che stato perfetto ma ti prende obbligo
andati in bagno con un righello è
tornata e dicendo la misura ma di cosa
lo decidete voi
ok ce l'abbiamo righello lo troviamo
subito non abbiamo il righello e casi
volevo misurarmi pena in realtà lo so
quanto 23 mm tra il grado di far
comparire un righello finto se eccolo
qua eccolo qui comunque misura misuriamo
il mio pollice tutti i 7 centimetri
obbligo fate uno scherzo alle vostre
fidanzate pronto ti lascio sei single e
attacco perché anzi due
porco peccato perché la solo che lascia
per ora chiamati avanti alcuni singoli
attacchi e aspetti che ti richiami reis
pronto amore amore ti lascio sei single
forse una piccola dell'azione poteva che
mi sta richiamando pronto anche cretino
amore sta girando il video amore
tranquilla un video ci sentiamo più
tardi ok amore amore sto lavorando non
mi fa preoccupare
ti lascio sei single poverino afa
lavorando
e uno scherzo con e dai signori gino
paoli sa mai
annusa tutti i piedi dei tuoi bellissimi
cugini e decreta quali sia il puzzone
riusciamo a farli arrivare
eccoli qua e dopo che questi qui siano i
piedi di lavinia buon odore fatto uno
scherzo telefonico alla fidanzata
dell'altro aridaje paola sono già marco
ciao semplice un problema e ricoh ha
avuto enrico avuto un valore perché
pensavo che tu avessi preso uno scherzo
seriamente e non ci sei cascato
ma qui davanti a tutta italia no ma sono
venuti risponde più né questo però alta
e scritto con uno senza guarda
meno male obbligo diventate biondi
aspetta
perché ci sono più tempo e cartone però
ricreate la creazione di adamo versione
covip
[Musica]
obbligo che avvicina di una pianta
grassa e ci appoggi la chiappa sopra a 7
attento ammette il culone onu mela finge
o no che sia matto a trovare pizzicato
ma spinge ma che spingono 6 spinge vita
perché per il bene della patria
io ho spinto la tuta che stava soltanto
verità svela peso e altezza
io sono alto un metro e 87 e peso 76
trucioli 172 per 112 kg tutto muscoli
altro mese ad enrico il patto di essere
il fratello più fuori forma luigi riello
verità siete mai usciti con qualche
vostro follower se ci avete mai parlato
male l'uno dell'altro momenti di rabbia
eccetera
assolutamente sì certo non ce le mandano
certo a dire l'altro ieri in corso
dell'ultima volta non c'abbiamo e mezzo
bisticcio che anzi chiedo scusa anche
chiesto quindi scusa siamo parenti e
colleghi quindi parenti serpenti per
forza di penserete cose ci si becca di
qualcosa che non sopporti dell'altro la
lentezza e lento io di te non sopporto
il prosciutto nelle orecchie delle volte
non ascolti se proprio mamma mamma mia
di coccio verità ce la manda trash push
aggravato durante questo gioco è sempre
risposto con la verità certo che no
è ovvio siamo qui a mentire verità hai
mai tradito io no io neanche vi siete
mai drogati in questa è una domanda
seria che intende poi per droga io mi
sono fatto una canna
io rispondono molto sinceramente a
questa domanda e gli uomini sono
quando ero ragazzino dai 14 ai 18 anni
tra lutti e cose del genere un periodo
abbastanza nero vabbè site tranquillo e
dukan due anni e mezzo fa bastava così
proprio scudo mangiato una banana in un
sol boccone
mi sa che non ce l'abbiano figurati se
non ha le banane guglielmo e puro non se
le mangia non ho trovato una banana però
una carota cene 212 ce la faccio dai
proviamo mai avete mai pagato per una
prestazione sessuale
[Applauso]
no invece hai mai mangiato qualcosa dal
corpo di qualcun altro ma che hannibal
lette dal corpo dal corpo io no scusami
vorrei che giammarco imitasse la rana
gigante nel muro di gu di non andare
troppo a fare sei mai stato attratto dal
tuo stesso sesso
no io obbligo a gianmarco di masticare
la gomma con la bocca chiusa
ma perché mastica la gomma gara bocca
aperta come una carota invece che la
famosa anno bene obbligo enrico a
mangiare con le posate in precedente ma
perché ti vuole morto la community
una somma poi facciamo apparire tutti
quelli che sono arrivati i pomposi in
sovrimpressione maledetti poi c'è il
codice è un messaggio sbagliato da
mandare adesso ha mai provato invidia
per un membro della sua famiglia ps non
il membro parte del corpo io posso dire
non invidia con astio ma di sana invidia
che ne so tipo le tetti di lavinia che
in via sperimentale
c'è qualcosa che vorresti ti fatti da
parte di scherzi viene social vg.sa un
fisico spettacolare
minchia lo vorrei avere un fisico del
genere io mi trovo bene in realtà con
quello che sono quindi tu sei sempre
stato si accontenta gode
panzer è gay assolutamente sì e io era
da tempo che mi aspettavo questa domanda
si che la ragazza vi obbligo a
schiaffeggiarsi a vicenda ma questo mi
stacca la testa quando hai mai spiato
qualcuno mentre faceva sesso non mi è
mai capitato questa volta city è
successo ero a mare tiro forse era
ferragosto si era medica era un pavone
in acqua sia anche quelli che ho in
un'altra storia della zia ogni spiaggia
due tizi trovavano in acqua superiore ma
arriva davvero che mi ha fatto dirimente
io invece avevo in mente quella che
c'era praticamente tutto quanto il lido
a guardarli ma era ti sei mai ma con una
bambola in mano io mi ricordo di si è
successo più di dieci anni fa era una
bambola di mia sorella prima dirige
questa è una verità che scoprirà gli
altri nomi sono ma con una delle top io
no perché certo voi 44 macchine
l'ambiente bambole io ero pieno di
bambola casa alla rosa qualsiasi
tipologia di d'olio cameron per chiudere
il video come fa guglielmo c'è qualcuno
visto che se non facciamo insegnanti
conoscendo commentava delle solite cose
che si fanno su youtube in genere uno su
youtube non si scrive non metterà è vero
non fate le solite cose che si fanno su
youtube
però chi si iscrive metterai non lo fa
tranne speriamo di avervi strappato una
risata ci vediamo alla prossima spero
che se dio vuole ci vuole
ciao